today I'm going to talk about the
long-standing theory that might have
kind of been confirmed or at least
hinted by an old as well as by the new
promotion photos of the nearest
Targaryen as you can see in a bunch of
promotional photos teasers as well as in
the official trailer itself Daenerys is
wearing an outfit that contains dragon
motifs and matches with colors of her
house which is not surprising every Lord
king or queen wears an outfit that
contains a symbol of his or her house
sigil meaning that there is nothing
surprising the Daenerys will finally
wear colors and motives on her dresses
that matches with her own house as we
can see in a few promotion photos the
nurse will also wear three had the
dragon pin which at first doesn't hint
not to mention confirm and it eerie but
on the other hand this same pin that
seems just as every other regular pen
might hint that the popular tree had the
dragon theory might come true in the
upcoming seasons before I go any further
let me just highlight this unlike most
of other TV shows Game of Thrones is a
show that has many times four share of
main events far in advance that's mostly
because showrunners David Benioff and
Dan Weiss have a show based on a book
series and show is not written on a
season by season basis let me just put
it this way by the time they started
writing the first episode of the very
first season they already knew about all
main events and deaths that will happen
in the upcoming season so they decided
to foreshadow most of them which is one
of plenty reasons this show is one of if
not the best TV show ever produced let
me give you a few examples Ned Stark's
death was foreshadowed in a very first
episode of the series as we all know Ned
Stark accompanied with John robbed Theon
bran and a few other man came upon a
dead direwolf a few months later we
found out that this dire wolf was killed
by a stag which actually foreshadowed
Robert Baratheon a stag getting Ned the
wolf killed by inviting him to King's
Landing while six paths that were left
behind upon the Darrell's death
represents Ned six children then we also
have Eamon or more accurately producers
foreshadowing John's real parentage
Eamon did not make claim or any
suggestion that he thinks John might be
more than a bastard but he did give a
huge hint in season 5 while having a
conversation with Sam about the nearest
he said a Targaryen alone in the world
is a terrible thing the camera cuts back
to
I'm listening and as soon as Amon
finishes his sentence John walks in at a
time most of us didn't even notice this
detail while some thought is just
coincidence
only to find out in the season six
finale that John snow is in effect a
Targaryen
in addition John's parentage had been
hinted more than once in season five
John snow was elected Lord Commander
while Stannis and his wife were staying
at Castle black
at one point cells said to Stannis that
John is only a bastard by some tavern
woman that was promiscuous on which
Stannis replied with perhaps but that
wasn't Ned Stark's way pointing out that
Ned Stark was too honorable to do such
thing let me give you one more example
which is Littlefinger for sharing time
and Lannister's dead in the 8th episode
of the fourth season Littlefinger had a
conversation with Robin who's afraid of
leaving home following his mother's
death Robin thinks it's safer for him to
stay inside but Littlefinger comforting
him by saying that people can die
anywhere Littlefinger said people die at
their dinner tables people die in their
beds they die squatting over their
chamber pots and few episodes later not
only that she was killed on her bed but
Timon Lannister was murdered while
squatting over his chamber pots with
this being said a nurse's pin might
still be nothing more than a regular pen
but taking into account all previous
hints that foreshadowed major events
that said much more this on first sight
regular pin might have much bigger
importance might be a clue that a tree
had a dragon theory will come true so
yeah as I've been saying this
three-headed dragon pin beside being a
regular pin that represents Targaryen
sigil might also foreshadow that beside
the nares riding dragon there will be
two more Dragon Riders that will ride
Ragle and bazarian let me introduce you
with a theory that this three-headed
dragon pin might be foreshadowing so
basically according to this theory
Rhaegar Targaryen statement in the
nurse's vision the dragon has three
heads means that each of the nearest
three dragons will have their own riders
for all of you that are not caught up
with the books and they're probably
wondering when the trackers say this let
me explain it to you in a few sentences
Daenerys saw visions in the house of the
undying in both in the books and on the
show but her visions are very different
in the books then there is so no vision
of Drogo and her son but she's so many
other visions of each one
the vision of her brother Rhaegar saying
the dragon has three heads
now if the three had the dragon Payne
truly for share of this prophecy coming
true which in my opinion definitely does
as I expect to see each dragon having
its own rider let's see who might make
up three had the dragon prophecy who
three Dragon Riders might be the first
one is obvious Daenerys has an
unbreakable bond and connection
Mondragon who is named after the nurses
late husband Khal Drogo and is the
largest one now let's see who might be
the second rider and the dragon would
that person ride after the season six
finale and huge revelation of Jon Snow's
true parentage john is not a bastard but
rather son of Lyanna stark and rhaegar
targaryen also known as the last dragon
it's pretty easy to assume that jon is
the second rider Jon Snow will most
likely ride ragel the dragon named after
his father but they're still the third
rider that is missing and is required to
fulfill the theory of the three Dragon
Riders but who that person might be it's
important to firstly halle that dragons
cannot be truly tame but can be bonded
with and trained probably the first
person that you have on your mind is
Tyrion Lannister as he already managed
to earn their trust and unshackle them
which would also fulfil his story of how
he wanted a dragon for his name they
only to be disappointed by loud laughter
from his family but will he really be
the one to ride Vissarion most probably
not Tyrion Lannister claiming the
dragons are intelligent much more than
most people and will quickly recognize
friend from foe in my opinions best
explanation and the only reason dragons
did not kill Tyrion dragons realized
that he's a friend and not an enemy
meaning that even though Tyrion did
manage to earn their trust he most
likely will not be the one to ride a
third dragon so beside people with
Targaryen blood beside Dany and John
there is still one more person required
in order to fulfill the three-headed
dragon prophecy but which person is it
well I believe in League plot that
states that the night king will kill
with zarion and reanimate him as his own
and the dragon and he'll eventually ride
him once he decides to attack the wall
and Seven Kingdoms I know that there are
most certainly a lot of you that don't
believe in it but upon Jon Snow's
mission beyond the wall being confirmed
by a lot of leaked photos
Bela's by the official trailer itself
say mission that will apparently result
the deaths of a few main characters and
with the death of its Aryan it does seem
pretty convincing that the night King
will be the third Dragon Rider if you
would like to know more details about
jon snow's mission beyond the wall which
from a theory quickly became a confirmed
event of the upcoming season while the
death and resurrection of mysterion is
still questionable feel free to check
out my previous videos
additionally beside is confirmed mission
that will most likely result with the
death and reanimation of bazarian which
would make the night King the third
Dragon Rider it would also fulfill the
three-headed dragon theory while it
would be nice to see Daenerys John and
Tyrion riding the dragons into battle
against the night King and his undead
army don't you think it kind of seems
too obvious to be the truth at least two
obvious for Game of Thrones however
while I can't tell for sure that Jon
Snow and the night King will ride the
nurses dragons I don't think that
Daenerys history had a drag on penis for
sharing the tree had a dragon theory
coming true in the very end of the
upcoming season there will most
certainly be three dragon riders while
Aegon the Conqueror and his sister wives
who descendant from all Valyria use the
last three dragons in the world to
conquer and unify the Seven Kingdoms in
the upcoming season the nurse will use
the last three dragons to try to retake
the Seven Kingdoms as well however at
some point of the seventh season the
nurse will realize that the real war is
between the living and the death and at
the moment in which we will find out who
may accept the three-headed dragon
prophecy well this promotional photo of
the nurse wearing the three-headed
dragon pain might foreshadow the
long-standing theory coming true it also
might be nothing else but a regular pin
representing House Targaryen before I
wrap up this video I mean should use to
with new promotional photos for season
seven released a few days ago there are
a few photos similar to already
published ones just taken from different
angle but there are also a few new ones
that are providing us first look at
certain characters such as this so beric
Dondarrion traveling and leading the
Brotherhood without banners to the north
we also get to see Davos we were just
about to leave Winterfell for
Dragonstone which matches where a photo
of Jon Snow living Winterfell that we
saw a few weeks ago then we can see a
new photo of torment giving a speech to
northern Lords as well as to
lords from the Vale and to the Knights
of the Vale as we can see Lord Royce in
the background next photo is the most
interesting one and takes place on
Dragonstone as we can see the nearest
Irian and grave warmer looking pretty
surprised and shocked at the same time
and while it's currently unknown what
caused their reaction wouldn't it be
amazing if they are actually looking at
jon snow riding ray go from leaked
photos we know that Jon Snow will meet
Daenerys at Dragonstone and will stay
over there for a few days or weeks so I
think there might be a chance of this
taking place other photos are as I
already said similar to the other
promotional photos released a few weeks
ago well tomorrow I'll publish a video
regarding the new released promotional
photos and as OH